hello everyone i'm alana welcome to my
channel where today we are catching up
on the halo infinite campaign overview
this is only six minutes
i waited until the end of my day today
because i thought it was going to be
like 40 minutes long um but we're on
xbox's youtube channel right now it says
it's only six minutes and 20 seconds i'm
hoping i'm looking at the right video uh
we are going to watch it in 4k which is
going to be crispy and beautiful and
yeah i'm really excited um i'm a very
big halo fan and i have been my entire
life i would say halo has like a really
special place in my heart
but i didn't really care too much about
four and five
um i've liked the way infinite looked
since the beginning even when everybody
was dunking on it and they were the
craig memes which are all
very good but i liked it because it
looked like og halo and uh the campaign
is obviously really important part of
that for me i feel like halo campaigns
have been like one to one with me
growing up weirdly um so i have really
high hopes for this
definitely dislike that the game is
launching without
uh co-op built into the campaign that's
a real shame but if we get anything out
of the next six minutes in apparently 20
seconds
i hope that it is
a cohesive
chief centric storyline
that doesn't come across like you need
extra content like a book or a comic
or um anything like that to make it make
sense and while i do have halo books and
comics and have watched many a halo
multimedia piece
i just want to contain story that's what
i really want from this experience and i
also hope that gameplay we see
looks like halo that's enough talking
sorry i'm just really excited but also
like scared
like i really want this to be good
um let's do it
[Music]
since the beginning
halo was about master correct and
cortana
partners protecting humanity
but that is now a distant memory
humanity is fighting for survival
the banished have risen defeated our
heroes
and taken control of the mysterious zeta
halo
we need a savior
we need hope i still don't know who this
dude really is
the pilot
we sure do
i remember talking to 343 about it we
have a new one last year
what's down there a weapon he's supposed
to be a weapon
how many guns do you need
nostalgia
because it looks like silent
cartographer that's what gets me about
it
my god
in the biggest campaign to date halo
infinite invites players to become
master chief and discover true spartan
freedom in the most wide open i would
love that i'm sure the halo experience
yet
still chief won't be alone on the
journey want to see mission is to
retrieve a new a.i
code name it's going to say story
context here but
it's been six months where have you been
following the events of halo 5 master
chief is searching for the answer to a
troubling question
what happened to cortana yes i was
created to lock down cortana but i don't
know why
what did she do that was so wrong
[Music]
i'm into it
oh i'm into that too
you can call in vehicles from there
that's neat
very good
it doesn't seem like a great
job for the longevity of the vehicles a
damaged world full of wonder mystery and
danger
oh
that looks dumb
gonna be like space dogfight type stuff
in the campaign and at every turn the
banished our hunting master chief and
the remnants of the unsc victory is
already ours we will meet
on the battlefield
the banished army is spread across the
surface
building fearsome strongholds and
outposts with no one to stop them
when the music's getting me man
i'm [ __ ] love halos
is that you you're safe now
yeah i was really surprised by how much
i liked the grappling hook as well in um
multiplayer that was my big thing that i
was like i'm not sure about that
incoming but
does bigfoot
it isn't
oh cool
boss fighty boys
players now have more freedom than ever
before to take down the banished any way
they choose
spanish facility up ahead chief
some kind of salvage operation
what do we do
shut it down
permanently
i'm a little bit less sold on that
that looks like a
lazy example but like a ubisoft s thing
they're like oh you'll have outposts you
can shut down in any order you want
which um
i made a video where i spoke to them
about the single player campaign and i'm
forgetting the details in my own video
now
that's cool
yeah like do we still get a solid linear
story i know when i spoke to them they
said
yes like it's back to grassroots halo
it's an homage to halos of olds which i
love
do you see that but i'm not seeing that
useful
if you like that kind of thing
but i am really impressed with this
gameplay wise this looks neat
halo infinite allows us all to become
master chief doing good spartans do best
to take down the banished
piece by piece this won't be an easy
fight
master chief will take on returning
favorites
and surprising new threats like the
agile skimmers all right with that you
can have some new threats that's okay
look out chief he looks angry and
something even more threatening
the forerunner's lies are at an end
you are not the future
exploring this vast and fractured world
will put spartan 117 to the ultimate
test
but where there is courage
there is hope
welcome to the new era of halo
listen
it looks
good is everyone trying to kill you
it kind of seems like it i don't love
her though
i'm not super into that performance
um
i feel like my my thoughts are already
synopsized
oh my
um
so i guess that makes sense that it was
a campaign overview because i was
expecting a story trailer which is a
different thing that is a campaign
overview that gave us an insight into
how the campaign will play and from a
gameplay perspective i think it looks
great um really cool very very into it
whereas
from a story perspective or like
how the linear narrative is going to
play out in the structures that they
have i'm
still kind of uncertain like it's more
than i have questions that i feel
negatively about it um
but gameplay-wise it looks like halo man
that's all i want is more halo in my
halo and i say that as somebody who like
is fine replaying the campaigns in the
master chief collection
ah very good how did the internet feel
about it that seems like a good like
ratio
battle damage on thief's armor looks
amazing shows craig the brute
i want to face four different enemy
factions in halo infinite including the
flood yeah we didn't see any of the
flood i feel like we probably won't
hmm
craig the brute proud to be part of
returning favorites amazing
beats that classic music i agree very
very very good
i know
stuff like this i feel like this like i
when halo infinite was first revealed i
did cry
um
this trailer had a similar effect of not
crying but i'm like oh man
like just just gets me in the feels
it seems like the reception's really
positive so
that's awesome
i
yeah i do like it um i think it looks
neat i i like
the examples of actually using vehicles
to fly around a larger map like not that
that wasn't a thing we didn't already do
in halo but often in previous campaigns
it's been a bit limited like you know
you get a scorpion and it takes you
between one place to the next place and
it's like very specifically designed for
you to have the tank between those two
places this seems like you can choose
what vehicles
um so that part of it is definitely a
lot less linear and you'll be able to
choose where you go so you know still
have questions maybe i should go back
and watch my own video i'll leave a link
in the description so you guys can check
it out because i've completely forgotten
what i said in it um when i when i
interviewed them
but i'm happy about this this looks
really
really good